the energy crisis looming over Europe
dominated the meeting of EU ministers in
Brussels
rationing gas ahead of Winter the best
and only way to reduce the eu's Reliance
on Russian energy
45 BCM corresponds today 15 cut in our
usual gas consumption between the
beginning of August and the end of March
that's why we have pointed to this
percentage as the target all member
states
should strive forward Russia is said to
further reduce supplies through the
north stream pipelines blaming a
technical fault at one of their stations
something EU ministers dispute
as of today there is no solution to the
ongoing equipment issues at the Portia
Avea compressor station there is no
solution whatsoever yet Siemens is
saying nothing they're trying to find
Solutions but there are none
as the west and Russia exchange economic
blows in response to Russia's war in
Ukraine European leaders say Moscow is
not a trustworthy partner the winter is
coming and we don't know how cold it
will be but what we know for sure that
Putin will continue
to play his dirty games
in misusing and blackmailing
by guard supplies Ukraine's president
followed May zielinski says Europe is
already at war with Russia just on a
different front Russian is bright all
this is done by Russia on purpose to
make it as difficult as possible for
Europeans to prepare for winter and this
is an open gas war that Russia is waging
against the United Europe This is
precisely how it should be perceived and
they don't care what will happen to the
people or how they will suffer from
Hunger due to the blockading of ports or
from winter cold and poverty or from
occupation these are just different
forms of Terror
nearly half of all the gas Europe needs
comes from Russia the supply is now down
to a relative trickle come winter if
European countries don't have enough
supplies taught up in time it means
certainly almost it will be a struggle
to hit homes and power cities Abdullah
Al Jazeera Brussels
well last week the European commission
proposed a 15 reduction in gas use for
all member states and suggested it might
have to make those cuts obligatory many
countries resisted that so the agreement
just reached in Brussels is a compromise
with a voluntary cut of 15 from August
to March the agreement includes opt-outs
so that the countries can cut less
states that are heavily reliant on gas
for electricity can avoid the reductions
and it's the same for countries
exporting 90 percent of their gas
capacity to other EU States
an EU official said Hungary was the only
member state that opposed the gas
reduction agreement
Noah Brenner is the executive editor for
operations at energy intelligence he
says that Europe is hoping for the best
but preparing for the worst
it's in a basket scenario where we have
a warm winter a short winter this plan
has really never put into full effect
and that would be you know there's not
an emergency declared where these Cuts
become more mandatory under that
scenario you know certainly the EU comes
out of the winter with still having some
gas in storage and without uh
significant disruptions to to things
like heating or or needs to to switch
fuels from gas to to fuel oil things
like that now under a worst case
scenario where we do have a colder
winter where it does last for longer
certainly the disruptions are are
greater um but you know they're
preparing for this by by activating
plans to like I said switch from gas to
fuel oil they're making sure coal plants
are available potentially extending the
life of nuclear plants so those plans
are in place but it certainly looks like
a much more uh Draconian cut through the
winter than we might see otherwise
addressing cost was one of the major
talking points for or the diplomats that
we're negotiating this agreement whether
you were impacted by Russian gas flows
or not the idea was by cutting down on
our usage we would then have more gas
and and it would stabilize the price it
would take away this kind of the
weaponization of gas that Russia has
been has been forcing on the EU but the
issue is is that
um you know beyond that I think that uh
you know we'll see
um prices are incredibly high and
they're simply going to be incredibly
High one way or the other what we're
looking for at best is stabilization not
necessarily drawing them down to
historical Norms that we would have seen
say a year ago but we also have to think
that gas is just one of the energy
Commodities that Russia sells to the
world I mean in the grand scheme of
things oil and and oil prices are at
incredible highs as well as refined
fuels and those prices are at incredible
highs as well so yes Russia is probably
receiving less Revenue overall but from
the gas side of of things but I would
say that it still has ample revenues
coming in from these other commodities